[Music]
[Applause]
thank rex this is a segment where
viewers try to find mistakes on our show
so far hundreds and hundreds of
challengers
no winners okay
we don't make mistakes
well tonight a fan named mike patterson
thinks he spotted an error he says it
happened during a recent interview with
modern family star ty burrell hey conan
i think i found uh an error on your show
um when you were interviewing that phil
dunphy guy from modern family where his
name is um you said you who are
styrofoam head at seven flags they treat
you like you're basically one of the
disney characters at disney it is the
thing that awaits all of us i'm going to
be the styrofoam conan someday at seven
flags
well as far as news and parks go seven
flags doesn't exist it's six flags
get your fat shirt kid
well first of all mike patterson we're
happy you took the effort to make this
response though obviously not the effort
to put on a shirt
he's busy he may have been wearing a
tube top we don't know
you're right i shouldn't assume right
well for your information
seven flags does exist it's a quality
theme park that i'm very proud to
endorse here to prove it is a real
commercial
gear up for excitement at the world's
greatest theme park seven flags you mean
six flags nope seven flags it's a real
place filled with real rides like the
ferris square
the merry-go-stand
and the bumper bikes
say hello to the styrofoam conan and his
famous character pals
mr mouse
doggie duck
snow black and the one dwarf you mean
seven doors kid you ask too many
questions treat your sweet tooth to our
famous snacks coke on the cob and wool
candy don't you need cotton candy wow
kid you're being a real mike patterson
and stop by a gift card for some great
seven flags merchandise including shirts
you know like civilized people wear so
pack a bag full of smiles and head down
to seven flags the extra flag means
extra fun
open from 11 to two the third tuesday of
every other month located on the former
site of three mile island
that's right
so there you have it seven flags is a
real place in fact from now on anyone
who correctly spots an error in our show
will receive a lifetime pass to seven
flags
slated for demolition february 2013.
so the challenge still stands if you
think you've spotted an error on our
show reported at teamcoco.com
haha i found an error we will sort it
out right here on the air let's see if
you have what it takes to make chump
meat
out of the maestro